bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors on le voit
ce deuxième anniversaire du mouvement
des gels et au jaune il coïncide donc
avec cette manifestation aussi du côté
de l'assemblée nationale sur pour
contester cette loi sur la sécurité
globale compenser vous d'abord oui
bonjour oui bah écoutez on va
effectivement chose que j'attends
effectivement même rang que la date
anniversaire du vous rendez gilet jaune
qui revendiquait déjà pas mal de choses
et qui dénonçait les dérives des forces
de l'ordre et je pense que cette loi
ajoute ajoute à ses dérivés et surtout
entraînera une dissuasion
lorsque les gens qui fument
régulièrement au coeur de partager ce
qui se passe avec le public qui n'est
pas forcément présents ou qui n'a pas eu
vent de ce qui se passe de la part du
gouvernement puisque la communication et
votre jeu rappelle que le ministre de
l'intérieur et une dernière avait dit
face aux caméras en direct que des
filets jaunes étaient entrés saccagé la
pitié salpêtrière alors que ce sont les
vidéos diffusées qui ont permis de
prouver le contraire et avec des
témoignages du personnel soignant en à
la nécessité de pouvoir diffuser sans se
sentir intimidé par cette loi qui dit
que le risque 45000 euros d'amendé et un
an d'emprisonnement si on diffuse dans
l'intention de nuire à l'intégrité
physique et psychique et en l'occurrence
comment ils peuvent s'occuper de juger
de cinq ans ils peuvent savoir quel
était l'intérêt premier alors que avant
tout c'est pour informer avec 500 pardon
alesi oui non je disais ce soir c'est
grâce à ses vidéos là que bon nombre de
personnes se sont rendues compte que il
y avait les dérives au niveau du
maintien de l'ordre en dehors des
quartiers populaires puisque c'est sur
des choses qui sont dénoncées depuis un
certain nombre de temps dans ces
quartiers que les gens ne peut
visualiser pas et là on a pu voir
l'ampleur d'ailleurs la française aurait
pu alors parvenue par un ancien
international par la ligue des droits de
l'homme
mais parler des parcs justement les
pratiques aussi du préfet en allemand
alors justement avec faouzi lellouche
vous avez déposé plainte avec
constitution de partie civile contre
didier lallement
le préfet de police de paris pour mise
en danger d'autrui et atteinte au droit
de manifester à la suite d'un
rassemblement notamment le 16 novembre
2019 au départ de la place d'italie
quel est l'objectif visé par sept
plaintes on a déposé plainte
effectivement pour cette première date
anniversaire l'année dernière et donc on
avait été empêchée de démarrer cette
manifestation le préfet n'avait pas
respecté la loi une notifiant pas
l'interdiction manifestation il avait je
pense ou prémédité le fait qu'on ne
puisse pas partir on avait déjà mis un
certain nombre de temps d'obtenir les
autorisations pour cent mais pour aller
là manifester en l'occurrence quand on a
posé plainte en charge de cette année on
n'a pas eu de retour du parquet de paris
je pense que nos sponsors eric enquête
alors contre des villes allemandes hong
kong en a réitéré cette plante mais
cette fois avec constitution de partie
civile ce sont pas les témoignages qui
manquent on a parlé la ligue des droits
de l'homme dans votre reportage
précédent alors qu'ils dénonceraient de
sécurité globale l'observatoire parisien
des libertés publiques et l'observatoire
âge violents des libertés publiques a
déjà édité des rapports dénonçant les
pratiques de maintien de l'ordre par
didier lallement à paris et à bordeaux
donc on a les éléments on a des
témoignages on a des gens qui ont été
blessées lors de cette manifestation et
au nom de tous les gens qui ont été
blessés aussi avant ça notamment les
mutilés on se doit de faire en sorte que
ce type de pratiques cessent et de
dénoncer par du coup par la même
occasion cette nouvelle loi précisent le
dos qui est votre mouvement il fait
enfin ils ont peut pas dire qu'il fait
mais en fait et aujourd'hui sont les
deux ans donc hors de du mouvement des
gilet jaune corps est-il justement de
cet élan au mouvement mais en
l'occurrence c'est beaucoup de gens qui
se sont manifestés à un instant t parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de dysfonctionnements
il
on sait très bien que ce que l'on le
mouvement revendiquant à plusieurs
occasions a la possibilité de le dire
sauf que le président n'a jamais
souhaité par les revendications on
allait rencontrer françois de rugy avec
fin novembre il y avait un certain
nombre de revendications qui résulté
dans d'un sondage qui avait réuni plus
de 45
vote et puis ensuite on a eu de la
plate-forme qui forait les bains.fr qui
a réuni 1 million de votes sur 25
propositions et camions en lumière 59
vérité sur les publicités on avait fait
un courrier pour demander à remettre ces
revendications là puisque les synthèses
de ces résultats ont été arrêtés fait
part par des laboratoires d'étude
universitaire qui se sont mobilisés
bénévolement pour pouvoir étudier ces
résultats cette consultation est leur
maison n'a jamais souhaité recevoir
c'est le ccc en tesla et en avril
dernier
il a précisé en avril 2019 par dont il
n'a pas précisé qui lançait la course au
stand pour le climat uniquement mais
qu'il rejetait tout le reste est qu'ils
considéraient du mouvement des jeunes
était terminé mais bon quand on a le
plus grand mouvement social jamais
survenues dans son pays on ne peut pas
décider il est terminé on doit le tendre
l'oreille et recevant les revendications
associés en l'occurrence il a refusé
il a aussi été interpellé par une
personne qui milité au sein du mouvement
qui a avait obtenu un rendez vous de sa
part qui lui avaient été promis lors du
salon de l'agriculture l'année dernière
cette personne est revenu vers lui par
des chefs de cabinet qui lui a premier
rendez vous est elle celle de cabinet
m'a demandé à qui reviendraient
lorsqu'elle a donné un mot non à jérôme
rodriguez france au boulot le chef de
cabinet l'ancien j'avais revenus et
rennes donc il n'a jamais eu d'intention
la part de berne amant d'avoir une vraie
réponse politique face à ce mouvement et
allait continuer à mettre en place
d'aidés des lois liberticides comme
celle que pendant pour laquelle on on à
la ligue des droits de l'homme et et
lunkin yankees à écrire au président
pour les accepter que ça ne respectez
pas que ça mettrait les droits des
droits de l'homme alors un mot peut-être
pour conclure sur la suite du mouvement
que vous souhaitez on est en pleine
crise sanitaire
c'est vrai que ça complique les choses
évidemment pour se mobiliser en plein
confinement il ya aussi une crise
économique qui se double à cette crise
sanitaire donc en termes de haut niveau
des revendications ça change aussi la
donne pour vous la suite du mouvement
moi je conseille à part qu'il fallait
qui suit ou pas enfin je veux dire on
peut pas passer une vie entière à
manifester dans les rues portent des
revendications sont claires je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
collectifs qui se sont créés
et qui sont nées du mouvement et les
fédérations qui sont nés chez party by
citoyenne et vous avez défaire des
fédérations de gilet jaune qui se sont
rassemblés pour pouvoir collectivement
travailler sur des sujets de fond parce
que effectivement en face on n'a pas de
réponse politique et donc il n'est pas
question de savoir si ça se poursuit ou
pas il est surtout question de savoir
quand est ce qu'on va réaliser que d'en
face on avait gouvernement qui n'écoute
pas et qu'est ce qu'on va faire pour que
ce pour que sachant qu'il faudrait des
profonds changements systémiques pour
que la participation citoyenne soit soit
fasse partie des prises de décisions
politiques parce qu'on se rend compte
qu'effectivement elle
ils ont le pouvoir de décider et qu'on
aime on n'a aucun pouvoir face à eux on
n'a pas la possibilité de se faire
entendre
donc ça me pose un vrai problème moi
j'avais démarré que cette pétition sur
la taxe carbone qui a faim qui a eu un
grand écho la taxe carbone on est sûrs
en scène qu'une bonne partie a été
détourné pour être reversé au cic du
d'éternité tout et du détournement
pardon de fonds publics est aujourd'hui
n'y a aucune sanction et aucune enquête
il n'y a aucune possibilité en tant
citoyen de faire en sorte que ça se
reproduise ce temps donc moins la
question que j'ai c'est qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait pour pouvoir
être entendue merci beaucoup à vous
presser les alliés d' au ski pour avoir
réagi en direct sur rt france